this should be against the law you
should not be able to lay to lie to the
America knowingly what do we do as
Americans to to say this is not okay to
the first amendment I think you well I
know when the first amendment doesn't
allow you to willingly lie Whoopi you
human whoopee cushion yes the First
Amendment does allow you to willingly
lie you have lied and the ladies that
you sit next to have lied about
virtually everything for the past five
years very fine people on both sides the
covid vaccine Works no mandate is coming
Jesse Smollett was going to be hanged
just in the last couple weeks how many
times have we played things where you
lie you lied about don't say gay by the
way we checked yesterday on the show it
turns out no gay people have been
arrested in Florida yet by saying gay or
even a straight person who might say gay
I would prefer that you didn't lie but
you are allowed to lie and I and I don't
want to put you in jail for lying